all right bethany yes bethany uh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally i grew up in connecticut
what city uh i was in a city actually a
little uh town called south bay
it's in between waterbury and danbury
tell me about your uh childhood growing
up you had both your parents uh yeah my
mom and dad i was the fourth child uh
first child and only child from my
father's second marriage
um
how would you describe your childhood
uh
to all outside appearances
modern
middle class america you know um pretty
normal
it appeared
it appeared um
but behind closed doors it was
very abusive you know a lot of
physical and verbal
[ __ ]
um
my father
was
a recovering alcoholic for a good bit of
my life
he ended up going back out actually that
was the most peaceful year or so of my
growing up was here he was drunk he was
way nastier way more violent
sober than he ever was drunk
um
i was always considered like an outcast
for my family like ever since birth
really
i wasn't
i feel at least
considered to be
a part of the family being from my
father's second marriage
um
the family never really accepted my
mother
you know what i mean um
so
i was always
treated differently you know than my own
brothers my cousins you know
i wasn't
accepted
i come from
a family of means you know
my father
he gave up his inheritance which was
half of a business that my grandfather
and his brother started when they came
home from world war ii
they started
a garage car dealership which
multi-million dollar business now
and when my grandfather retired my
father turned down
my grandfather's half of the business
um
my father was
an employee for the town of south berry
he ended up retiring as the assistant
foreman for the public works department
um did you finish high school
i actually dropped out my freshman year
i got my ged shortly thereafter um
then i was going to college in vermont i
was
going with the goal of becoming a
veterinarian
but then i got my car accident and i got
my brain injury and that through my
education off the rails
that happened a week after my 20th
birthday i got a 20th birthday um
my birthday is july 17th
my accident happened july 25th 2001.
just young and dumb and drunk it was a
sunday afternoon
we were doing a side job
up in
dutchess county right over the border
from sharon we were drinking all day
like you know we went to the bar for
lunch
um
needless to say when we got back to
the guy who were working for his house
my friend who got me the work for the
day
had to park the guy's truck his car was
parked in the driveway
so i had to move the car
we both went flying up a dirt road at
like 100 plus miles an
hour no problem coming back though when
i hit the brakes they locked up on me
and
i cut the wheel into the woods
instead of going out this is right on
route 4.
my mind always i could see was hitting
like a minivan full of kids coming home
from soccer or church or something so
i caught the wheel into the woods car
flipped landed on its side
i climbed out all i could think about
like
shock is a funny thing
i had a bag of weed and a bowl in my
pocket and this is 20 years ago and that
stuff was still bad
and all i think was i'm gonna get
arrested for the weed and i threw it
into the woods and that's the last thing
i remembered
woke up two and a half weeks later in
hartford hospital
i was lifestyle helicoptered from sharon
hospital
um my face was shattered my jaw was
wired shut
um
my arm
my titanium pins and plates here my leg
was [ __ ] up
um
that really just derailed my life right
there you know i mean so you hit another
car no i hit a tree you hit a tree
that's the reason i cut my wheel into
the woods is yeah i
you didn't want to hit somebody
i mean your whole life in a moment like
that flashes before your eyes like time
i mean time's just a concept of the
human mind anyway it's not really
real at least as far as i'm concerned
but it slowed down
like to
felt like hours that that second you
know where
i made that decision and
then hit the tree it just you know and
i
you had a friend in the car no thank god
it was just me
no one else was injured nothing like i
i'm so grateful for that but you're a
drug yeah yeah very much so um
you know it was my fault you know i
shouldn't have been behind the wheel of
the car and i definitely shouldn't have
been driving the way i was driving you
know
but i mean [ __ ]
took me a long time to get over that i i
was so just
depressed angry miserable like oh
i just wished i had died in the accident
really like
i had no clue why i was still alive like
why why i survived that because i
shouldn't i wasn't wearing a seat belt
like one of the only reasons i'm alive
like
i mean and this is just serendipity like
the lady
that lives across the street from
the guy who we're working for
is a [ __ ] trauma nurse she was on her
day off from work working in her garden
when the car accident happened
only other person around was my friend
who was just as drunk as i was
if she weren't there i would have died
not a doubt in my mind about it
so what happened after the accident
um
i started systematically destroying my
life
you know
um
i was miserable i started drinking like
extremely heavily
um were you on painkillers yeah i was on
four occasions a day i was on some other
stuff too when i first got out but that
was my regular regimen
after uh
they took me off the i think it was
dilaudid and morphine for breakthrough
pain over the course of like the first
like a couple of months like
i'd take the oxy every six hours and
then
every two hours in between that six
hours so i take the oxygen and then like
two hours later i could take the
morphine
and then two hours after that i could
take the dilaudid
and then two hours after that i could
take the oxy again the morphine and that
allotted in between those i was only
supposed to take if i needed them and
this went on for quite a while
um the breakthrough pain like that that
i was tapered off was fairly quick
and i understood what those were
like everybody knows what morphine is
you know and
hydromorphone you can kind of piece that
one together too
but i had no clue
what oxy was you know it hadn't started
hitting the news yet
i had no clue it was something that my
doctor prescribed to me so it obviously
had to be all right you know what i mean
um
until
2003 when i got cut off no taper
nothing
i went in for my monthly visit and he's
like here this is going to be your last
prescription
and
yeah i found out real quick that it was
hillbilly heroin as they called it
and
one thing led to another i was buying
pills on the black market you know but
with the whole opiate epidemic hitting
the news and everything
price went from ten dollars for a pill
within six months a year it was freaking
50 60 70 80 100 a pill
and i ended up making the switch both to
heroin and to injecting
and
you know it's been a run ever since you
know here when's your drug today
yeah
um
i was clean for almost six years before
i ended up coming here
to new york um
but i found you in washington square
park but where do you hang out normally
i live on the corner of west 8th street
and the sixth avenue so right here yeah
literally like
diagonally from the park yeah
and you've been homeless for how long um
it'll be three years the end of this
winter
like
february march somewhere in there it'll
be three years
what's it like being homeless in new
york it's rainy and cold sometimes
yo i i mean
it there's a truth i call it like
there's the most
miserable moments i've ever had you know
where there's
just
seems like there's no hope like there's
no reason to keep going
and then
out of nowhere like
just somebody whether it's somebody that
i already know
or whether it's somebody i've never met
before but like
some of the most
wonderful amazing beautiful people in
the world
one will come up and they'll just
recharge me spiritually i like to say
you know
because
like i said there's times when you
really want to give up but then
one of these people will come up and
they'll take their time and it's not the
money i mean yeah money helps i needed
to support my habit
feed myself [ __ ] like that but
it's more the
human interaction the kindness them
recognizing my humanity
you know um
taking the time to see me for more than
just what you see you know not reading
not not
you know
making a
decision about me without reading the
book you know i think new yorkers are
much kinder than their reputation
[ __ ]
no the one
i find there's three three classes
people
you have
your [ __ ] the people that will
purposely go out of their way to try and
make your life harder to try and hurt
you whether it be
emotionally spiritually physically okay
and thankfully that's a small portion of
the population
you know i'd say
half a percent maybe
then
you have what i consider the worst is
the the people that are indifferent
you know
everybody knows who around here knows
it's me that lives on that corner
and that stuff is mine
my
sign that i sliced this homeless trans
woman disowned by my family
struggling to survive any kindness even
just a smile is truly appreciated god
bless
i'll be sleeping
and there
somebody will be ransacking my my
belongings
robbing me
and people just walk by
they don't say
excuse me are they supposed to be doing
that or trying to stop they do nothing
they just walk by like
what's happening is okay
i mean i've had my shoes stolen i've had
you know
everything stolen i mean there's nothing
i've had that hasn't been stolen or
thrown out by the police because they're
trying to help me big joke there
um
but
that indifference i find that to be the
biggest
problem
and then you have that other like half a
percent of people that are just these
beautiful people you know they just
they haven't been blemished by
the world that we live in
you know um
there's this one family that is
i mean so wonderful to me
they have a little daughter ella b i
think she's six
um
late spring early summer it was her
birthday and she came walking by me
she's got balloon in her hand you know
like she looked like the birthday girl a
little group of her friends are with her
and you know i try and be very congenial
to the people around especially people i
see on a regular basis my neighbors and
they're like i'm like hey happy birthday
sweetheart hey and
for some reason i just happen to have
this little package of little girls
barrettes
like hold on a second i have a present
for you
and i gave this little girl her name's
ella b like this beautiful little blonde
girl her mother is
a beautiful woman she could be a model
probably is
i gave her the barrettes and you know
she was all excited she's like thank you
so much and you know she she went on her
way with her mom and her friends
hour two later this little girl comes
back and mind it was her birthday
she has one of her balloons in this book
the book is a story about this young
black girl that's getting harassed and
you know made fun of and [ __ ] like that
and this little girl felt like the book
related to
what i'm going through as a trans woman
and i mean she had me bawling my eyes
out i'm about to cry right now because
just thinking about it
not only just the fact that this little
six-year-old girl thought to do
something for me give me a gift on her
birthday
but
her mother
allowed this
you know
most parents even just dog parents
you know do everything they can scuttle
their children their animal whatever as
far away from me as quickly as possible
you know what i mean so for
this woman to
allow her daughter to have interactions
with me
on that level you know
with no bias no
not teaching her to be afraid it's
beautiful man
i wish there were more people like that
you know
because then maybe things wouldn't be
the way that they are
that people just had a little bit more
compassion
you know
you don't need to give me money like my
sign says
a smile as you're walking by when i say
good morning
you know not ignoring me
like pretending you don't hear me i
can't tell you how many people will be
sitting there looking at their phone
i'll ask them for the time
no they hear me because they'll look at
me when i ask them the question
and they just keep walking
you know i'm asking you for the time
i'm not asking you for money i'm not
asking for anything but
simply
a word a syllable
a couple syllables sorry like you know a
little bit of respect yeah exactly you
know treat me like i'm a human being you
know
people think india is the most classist
country like in the world it's
absolutely not they just admit it
america is way more classist than they
are we just try and say no everybody's
equal [ __ ]
i can't even go to the bathroom in that
park
every day i get traumatized just trying
to use the bathroom in that park
just today i was in there i wasn't even
in there two minutes
and the park police are in there
slamming the door
get out of here you've been in here
forever
like
i literally was in there for two
minutes
i've barely gotten my pants down
and they're telling me i gotta get out
get
all those little [ __ ] rich [ __ ]
and not only that but they tell me i'm
in the wrong bathroom all the time like
after the couple of cease and desist
letters i had my lawyer sent them
that's why they do what they do now and
center it around something that's
supposed i guess it isn't discriminatory
you know
tell me about being trans here in new
york city
is it difficult
it's a lot worse than i thought it would
be
um
have you been trans how long have you
identified i've my whole life i didn't
come out until like my early 30s
um been just about 10 years now maybe
so
i was terrified to come out
on something happened when i was a child
and it told me i needed to hide who i
was you know and i didn't tell my father
was suffering so badly from dementia
that that fear was lifted from me
the sexual abuse when you're young
i prefer not getting into that yeah but
yeah
there's
what is your drug today
and how do you support your heroin habit
i panhandle like
i don't steal i don't
do you know i go around sometimes like
people throw out a lot of damn good [ __ ]
around here
i'm perfectly fine stuff i picked up a
couple of months ago
somebody
threw out an air conditioner it was
brand new it was still wrapped in the
plastic
the only reason i could see that they
threw it out
on the back part
the part that's outside the window that
was a little tiny dent and a little chip
in the paint
that was the only thing that i could see
i looked it up this was a 600 air
conditioner
do you still have contact with your
family
no no i haven't talked the last time i
talked to anyone in my family was my
mother
um she stole my service dog
when i ended up out here
and
i called her
just about two years ago now that was my
last attempt to try and get penelope
back from her
um
but no i i haven't called um
you know she has no clue how to get a
hold of me like
i don't have a phone i don't believe in
them i won't get one
i use a friend's address
to receive mail you know a sweet couple
that live over on 9th street they let me
get an email that i need to get at their
address you know that's nice
yeah it saved me from using like general
delivery off that's what i'm talking
about the new yorkers can be very kind
yeah no no one like i was saying the
ones that are kind i mean they're just
these beautiful people
you know
they'd give you the shirt off of their
backs
if they could you know
but unfortunately those kind people are
way outnumbered by the
ones that are just indifferent
the ones that'll sit there and pretend
to be on a phone call
when they walk by me or
you know they'll turn their head pretend
to be looking at something across the
street or
you know just
anything to
pretend i'm not there
you know pull out the air pods and put
them in you know when they see me or
whatever you know like
the people that you sit there and watch
pull a cigarette out of their pack put
it back in their pocket excuse me thank
you spare a cigarette
ah i just bummed this one or you know
it's like
what what do you need to like a homeless
person for in the first place like what
what's wrong with that picture you know
what i mean
like
i i don't get a lot of it i i try i
consider myself a people watcher like my
minor in college with psychology
so
i try and make sense of it but i can't
you know there's just so much of it that
in any rational sort of sense just it
can't make sense
you know and then the people that are
purposely nasty there's this one woman
in the neighborhood we call the dragon
lady
she works
for the village alliance okay um
if you just got here you might not have
had any run-ins with the village
alliance yet but
it's this group of uh workers they go
around with trash cans and brooms and
stuff they're in each neighborhood you
know they have their own thing but they
clean up the neighborhoods stuff like
that pick up the trash
um i imagine she works in the office or
whatever for them but this woman she
goes around and she purposely tries to
emotionally and spiritually damage
people like me she'll come up and start
screaming at you
you're a parasite
you're you're a junkie you're a [ __ ]
this that any other thing you know
and
what i've learned is
she's just trying to get you to attack
her
you know she wants you to
feed into that negative energy
because
i did for a while you know i'd sit there
and give it back and forth with her [ __ ]
you you know
end up in jail that's what that's her
goal that's her goal honestly um
i mean one morning my first winter here
is really cold so i was sleeping in a
cardboard box
you know i made a little little hut out
of it and i woke up to this woman
kicking me in the face
a young college student and college girl
chased her off actually
she called the police for me police
wouldn't even take a police report on
this woman
i had witnesses i even saw this woman
kicking me in the face and they wouldn't
do anything about it
but um
through time and through
my own spiritual growth i learned how to
deal with people like her instead of
feeding into her
i
i
i found a [ __ ] tonight um first time i
did this i was amazed by the reaction i
got from her
like man i'm sorry i i really am that
you're so sick
that in order to feel better about
yourself that you need to try and harm
somebody like me you know
as if my life isn't difficult enough
already as if i don't struggle with
enough already
like
you gotta come and for no reason try and
bring me down trying to trying to harm
my psyche like i'm so sorry that you're
that sick that with all your privilege
all of that that in order to feel better
about yourself you got to do this to me
and other people like me
and yo she did not know what to do
she started calling me a [ __ ]
like you know
just really you know
way below like what you think someone
like this woman would act you know
this is what you'd expect some like
teenage girl like drunk like having a
rant would sound like
not some
educated like
older upper middle middle class white
woman on the streets of new york you
know
and so she made me like 40 bucks that
day too because people walking by saw
how i was dealing with her
and they came up and they were just like
here wait yo
you know and ever since then like i've
started dealing with people like that
like that that whole saying kill them
with kindness
i mean it doesn't always work but
i mean more often than not it defuses
and you know turns the situation
in my favor
and i also have a goal in living out
here now that it's my choice like
i want to change people's perceptions of
what a homeless person is
because
we're not all just some drugged out
like
waste of life that's
gonna mug you as soon as there's nobody
else on the street you know
honestly like
they're the outliers in the homeless
community
yeah well if you turn around and you
leave your purse well a lot of them grab
it and run away
you know good chance but watch your [ __ ]
but you know they're they're not violent
nasty bad people they're they're just
people that the game of life is [ __ ]
unfortunately stacked the cards in a
really you know got a shitty hand you
know
and
not everybody has the resources to be
able to deal with that they don't have
family they don't have money
you know the system looks at them oh
you're queer or you're black you know
like so [ __ ] you you know because that
that's the way it is a lot of the time
like the police won't do a thing to help
me i had a hate crime committed against
me the other night i still haven't heard
from the detectives i've been harassed
by this trash truck driver for months
and months every night about 4 am he
drives by my corner and screams at me
kill yourself back at all sorts of nasty
stuff
um a couple of weeks ago though it
started getting physical dude got out of
his trash truck chased me around for
about five minutes with a shovel so i
ran out in the street and tried to flag
down a cop who wouldn't stop by the way
he just flew by me as i'm out in the
middle of 6th avenue trying to stop him
um
maybe a week after that
he was driving by and out of nowhere
this [ __ ] glass bottle came whizzing
by my head
thankfully he missed and i see the trash
truck hope lying down a street
i called the police
i filed the complaint they actually did
pick a complaint for me this time
but as far as i know nothing happened
because of it because
four or five days after that
i had just gotten back it's a little
after midnight i think
this wasn't even two weeks ago now and
i bent down i was kneeling down to look
through some food that somebody had left
at my spot while i was gone you know and
out of nowhere
crash right in the back of my head i get
hit with a glass bottle
[ __ ] shattered on my head smashed all
over the sidewalk
you know and as he's driving away he
said something along the lines how'd
that feel [ __ ]
these two girls they're here on vacation
from florida i got them to stop they
witnessed it and they called the police
for me and the like and
which we call it they sent one squad car
one squad car for this they didn't even
want to take pictures of the broken
glass on the ground
nothing
like you know
if that would happen to a trans nyu
student
half the department would have done that
you know
they would have talked to detectives
from the hate crimes bureau like
i haven't even talked to a detective i
talked to two beat cops
you know
i mean it is i guess being handled by
detectives i don't know whether it's
being handled like as a hate crime or
not which it should be
um because a friend of mine
who lives on a street called and shot to
see what the status was
you know because i wanted a restraining
order against this guy and like like
that for my own safety you know
but they haven't even come to tell me if
they've arrested them
or anything like that
you know like
if i was an nyu student like i'd be
getting like hourly updates by text you
know
they'd be calling me asking is my head
all right would they like me to come
would they would i like them to come
over and put an ice pack on it for me no
seriously i mean that's a little a bit
of an exaggeration but
their case would be cared about
and i bet you until my friend called
they probably just kind of put it over
the side like well whatever you know
until they realize that somebody cared
you know because that's the thing is
they don't think anybody cares about us
you know
and maybe true i don't have any of my
blood family the family that i've made
here for myself i'll take that family
any day over the people that i was born
into any day of the week
you know these people don't have to have
me in their lives you know they choose
to have me and that's special
all right bethany thank you so much for
sharing your story
not a problem i wish you the best of
luck out there
thank you very much dude i
appreciate it i hope it can do something
good for
someone else you know yeah thank you
very much
god bless
you